it's really pretty amazing
you know to go from
coming out here getting first of all you
come out here with a series uh and then
and then you know you do a few guest
Bots and you're you're doing okay but
then you get together with some guys and
create a comedy show like they were
there people
like comedy people that were furious
with you guys you know like how like UCB
people or you know people that had been
like pushing comedy comedy comedy you
know probably I don't know I mean maybe
I don't know I don't know um again I
didn't come from the comedy world yeah
it was a really weird I did feel like
most of the people who were doing the
things like what we were attempting to
do yeah were coming from the sketch
comedy world or the Improv Comedy world
because what we were doing was very
improvi and and
it wasn't sketchy but it was you know
there's definitely you're doing bits and
you're you know sure but what we thought
was you know we want to approach this a
little bit more like a drama and just
have it be that the situations are so
insane that that's what's that's what
makes it funny that we weren't trying to
be overly clever or or overtly funny in
our performance style right you know um
it was really honestly very very heavily
influenced and and um spurred on by
having watched the British office and
having been watching Curb Your
Enthusiasm those were the two shows that
made us go oh
it doesn't have to look that good yeah
you know what I mean it just looks very
handheld and it looks like somebody
turned on a bunch of fluorescent lights
opened the shades and and you know and
uh and then you could roll on it if you
had funny people
um doing funny things like a loose
naturalistic kind of feel yeah yeah and
there was these you know there's this
category of prosumer cameras that were
coming out which were somewhere between
just a handheld video camera and a
professional camera yeah
that could shoot in what was at the time
a pretty high resolution that could
capture a lot of light
um and so it it was the perfect time to
do it YouTube did not exist yet oh wow
when we first years the first version of
it we shot was uh that we the first
version was at the end of 2003 so almost
almost exactly 20 years ago which is
crazy
um so it took about four or five years
to get to the air right it took uh we
shot we ended up shooting two or three
different versions of the first of the
home movie that we we called a home
movie right and then and then before we
felt like we really got it and then we
shot a second episode as a home movie
just kind of as proof of concept like
hey this isn't one up they want that
yeah
um and this was probably in 2004 and
then we shot the and then when we got
picked up or when we got the pilot order
from FX we shot that and
of the fall of 2004.
uh so it was really not pretty quick it
was a year from the time we first picked
up cameras until we were shooting with
FX yeah yeah yeah so it was pretty it
was relatively quick was it um being in
something that you produced and wrote
yourself was that was that something
that surprised you that you were doing
that
yeah I never I never thought that I
would do that I never thought that I
mean I always thought like wow writing
directing producing that sounds like
something I would want to do at some
point but it happened much quicker than
I thought it was going to happen
um and it was really spurred on by
um I mean I got to give mcelhaney a lot
of credit because he you know he was the
one who's like let's go let's do this
and that energy was so infectious to me
that I I was like yeah let's go and and
we would just call our friends and I
said guy so secure huh what's he
got going on
get the World by the ball so much I
don't know you'll have to talk to him
about that yeah buying soccer teams and
Jesus Christ take it easy
no I mean that's fantastic and I mean
and it's I think it's also really
and it's I think it's a big ingredient
of you guys success is that there's
something organic there you guys weren't
you're not like a boy band you know like
the TV version of a boy band that was
all cobbled together you know you guys
are in this sort of the same vein as you
know Kids in the Hall you know and you
know comedy groups that started
low rent and then stuck together and you
know and and also too Jesus Christ it's
hard to keep that kind of
group marriage alive you know and you
guys have done a pretty fantastic job of
it yeah I I it's always felt to me more
like being in a band yeah than than
being on a show yeah um
just because as you know I mean most
shows not not every show but most shows
the writers aren't maybe there's a
couple of writers that act on the show
but it's not like it's but they're
separate and the producers are not the
actors and the you know so the fact that
we were writing our own music and
Performing our own songs it always felt
like we were a band
um and so you know there's those moments
of uh of yeah look we fought a lot in
those first three or four seasons but we
try we always try to make keep it up
make uh keep it about the the work and
and not about our egos and we we got
better and better throughout the years
at recognizing when we were fighting for
something because our ego was hurt yeah
versus fighting for something because we
really thought thought that it was
creatively the best choice that is
definitely a learned skill yes you know
yes
um but it took it took a while and and
now we've gotten to a really good place
where we're happy to defer to whoever
has the strongest feelings about any
given thing because we're like that
might just be exhaustion that's been one
of my line
uh for years is and you know like in
talking over a bit on the floor yeah and
going well why not do this and then I
and then somebody they'll you know
person a will go yeah that could work
but I really think this aspect you're
forgetting in person B goes you know I
don't think it'll work because and then
like I said I've used this line before
I'm like you know and I realized I don't
care that much you know but just that
amount of dialogue right there realized
I don't care so do whatever yeah it
doesn't matter it's just it's not you
know I got a lot yeah I'm hungry and I
want it and I'm sure you guys have
figured this out
there's it's not a science no it's like
you know they're neat we need a joke
here and then there's no like this is
the best joke it's like no this is the
one we're gonna go with and you know and
somebody might not like it but it's we
got to move on yeah I don't really want
to work with people who are like no this
is the best joke yeah no I don't give a
what else I've been around some of
them and it's like it's usually
fear-based yeah you know yeah it's
usually like afraid that they can't make
more and that they gotta
no there's like especially
well the a strip show Conan show kind of
deal you can't be precious about stuff
you know it's you somebody said like my
my friend Tommy once said if you you put
an idea out there it gets shot down
okay if you still think it's good
try it one more time and then very very
very rarely try a third time but never
go beyond three right like No And but
they're I mean there have been you want
to like go way past it try it seven nine
times to where it becomes funny
you know what I mean no that's yeah when
you get to when you go from like one
kind of funny then in like five like
okay it's pretty funny and then you get
through this whole area where it's like
shut the up and then you get to 25
times and you're like oh okay it's the
funniest thing ever yeah yeah yeah I do
like that sometimes I'll do that on
purpose right right just because I do
actually find that kind of thing
hilarious